I know my kids are going to know all of
me either by what I tell them by what
they hear out of my mouth or what they
see that I've already said before they
were around that's the thing and I
didn't know when I was younger and I was
partying and having and I won't I don't
feel bad about the narrative like I I
even this craziest stuff I experienced
like okay both of us partied like
starting at week nine yeah which is like
I know it's like didn't know I was ever
gonna have kids yeah no I couldn't
picture it right no me neither and my
parents split up so I didn't think that
families stayed together and I didn't
think I would ever have kids and I just
sort of lived you know when you're young
and you're just like immortal and you're
just a hedonist having the best time
ever I don't even mix Tylenol and Advil
now
oh how the pendulum swings